mientras los restos del puente cuelgan
sobre el río machú debajo de él continúa
la búsqueda desaparecidos
los lugareños ayudan a los socorristas
que han rastreado el río durante toda la
noche
la gente estaba colgada del puente
después del accidente pero se resbalaron
y cayeron al río cuando se derrumbo
no dormía en toda la noche porque ayude
en la operación de rescate ya había
muchos niños al hospital
la centenaria pasarela había reabierto
hace pocos días tras más de seis meses
de obras de renovación los espectadores
disfrutaban de la visita en la Popular
atracción mientras en India se celebraba
el tiguali la mayor festividad del país
sin embargo mientras cientos de personas
abarrotaban el puente los cables
metálicos se rompieron y la estructura
de 230 metros de longitud se dio Poco
después del anochecer los servicios de
emergencia no llegaron al lugar hasta
dos horas después y aunque consiguieron
poner a salvo a las personas que estaban
en el río muchos otros no sobre
mi amigo murió se llamaba feroz
estábamos atascados sin poder avanzar
cuando estábamos en medio del puente
este se derrumbó de repente
gujarat es el estado natal del Primer
Ministro narendra Molly el dirigente
indio prometió indemnizar a las familias
y el gobierno creó un comité para
investigar uno de los peores accidentes
de la última década